so how do you choose which market
segmentation to use you want to look for
buyers that are feeling strong pain
points and who also have money a sense
of urgency and a good fit with the
features of your current version of your
product we can go with your graphic
segmentation and choose our own city to
start with this will allow us to map out
all the local competitors and easily
research potential clients at the dog
parks on the other hand we could focus
on behavioral segmentation and target
people with dogs who vacation frequently
focus focus focus it will help you to
develop a clear messaging and will make
it easier to decide what product
features to build next you can focus on
building the best product for this
segments needs don't compromise on an 80
percent satisfaction of few segments
make one specific segment very very
happy with your products
let's ask Geoffrey more for his advice
on choosing the most valuable market
segment to begin with